c'est une victoire pour le rassemblement
de la droite et du centre au niveau des
yvelines de nombreux candidats issus de
la majorité au conseil départemental
sympathisants du parti les républicains
ou classé divers droite sont élus au
premier tour arrive en tête des
élections municipales
c'est le cas notamment de karl olive à
poissy de jean michel fourgous à
elancourt ou d'arnaud perica à saint
germain en laye ce succès se fait aux
dépens de la république en marche
le mouvement du président de la
république rade son pari dans les
yvelines principales illustrations la
quatrième position dan france simon
candidate investie à versailles loin
derrière le maire sortant françois de
mazières réélu avec 63% des suffrages
autre exemple à rambouillet gilles
schmitt arrive en troisième position
avec 22% des voix devant lui véronique
matillon candidates issues de la
majorité sortante et l'écologiste david
jutier puis à limay sébastien duprat
investi par la république en marche
arrive en dernière position avec 11%
loin derrière le candidat communiste
eric rouleau autre succès d'une
candidature communiste signe du maintien
de la gauche dans ses bastions à la
verrière la maire sortante nelly duthu
arrive en tête avec 40% des suffrages
pas de succès au 1er tour à cause de la
division des candidatures de gauche mais
une situation attrape ou à guyancourt
françois morton arrive en tête mais une
candidature commune avec olivier paréja
aurait pu obtenir plus de 58% des voix
à noter la réussite des candidature
écologiste à rambouillet andrésy et
carrières sous poissy
enfin le rassemblement national confirme
son implantation à mantes-la-ville seule
commune dirigée par une majorité issus
du parti de marine le pen le candidat
cyril note obtient 33 % des suffrages